and our hardware labs research team has
been leveraging facility improvements to
bring major enhancements to the Transtar
product line i will further optimize
communication and safety aboard Talos
Norton newest enhancements to the
transcribed unit a portable personal
assistant device that is capable of
voice chat email station navigation and
inventory management this apparatus
projects an LCD display screen that
allows the user to navigate through
station maps neural mod installs
weaponry and other modes of
communication where labs technicians
have been prototyping a new piece of
equipment that deconstructs matter this
dangerous device attracts all objects
within a short radius and recycles them
into material fragment our team has been
beta testing a high-tech gadget that
warps energy fields star power supplies
proved to be stable in a baby blankey
airing operators are self-regulating
robotic units that maneuver autonomously
they perform a variety of mechanical
repairs aboard Talos want to protect
their delicate wiring all operators are
now fitted with a small shield that
guards electronics from exposure heat
damaged circuits can cause
irregularities in the unit's behavior
while rare there have been documented
occurrences of aggression by malfunction
these units should be terminated
immediately but well as most popular
weapon the glue cannon or jelly foam
lattice organism obstruct ur fires a
quickly stabilizing stream of in
capacitance own it can be used to
immobilize - to avoid corrosion from the
glue foam hardware labs Tech's have
designed a rust resistant carbon steel
to line the glue cannon pipes
cutting or is a device that releases a
psycho luminescent night light to
attract - organisms it can be thrown or
secured to surfaces testing whether
typhoon react to cycle luminescent
stimuli requires increased safety
measures so the 2032 hardware update
overview for both one
[Music]
you